welcome back to pft pm week 15 is in the
books it's tuesday and that means as
always we hand out the awards there are
no statues there are no plaques there
are no cash prizes just the satisfaction
of a job done mds is here to help us do
the job on the four categories offensive
d
player of the week defensive player of
the week rookie of the week and coach of
the week hello mds we'll get right to it
with offensive player of the week you're
up
well i'm gonna say kudos ryan tannehill
on a job done
you are my offensive player of the week
uh you know i know a lot of people
credit derrick henry for the titans
offensive success but i really think
we're underplaying what ryan tannehill
has meant to derek henry i'll give you a
great stat and we posted it on pft today
henry has 3
249 rushing yards in 26 games since
tannehill became the starter henry had
1735 rushing yards in his 26 games
before that look they both make each
other better but i wanted to give ryan
tannehill some credit three passing
touchdowns two rushing touchdowns he had
an excellent game on sunday
mds you got the aggie i got the aggie
transfer and kyler murray in playing the
sooner bowl he out dueled jalen hurts
and i just thought he was really good he
passed over 400 yards 406 threw three
touchdowns and had the one interception
but was really good 29 yards rushing
and a touchdown there and and it's just
amazing how quickly he and deandre
hopkins have really gotten it together
and had that chemistry and and hopkins
went over 150 yards uh on sunday was
just outstanding again and you look at
how long it's taken tom brady to connect
with mike evans and it is amazing how
quickly the cardinals have gotten that
done but congratulations to kyler2 he
got his first pro bowl and he got it
over tom brady mike
that's right and uh you know i i've
learned that if you say kyle murray fast
enough it comes out calamari that's one
thing and secondly to the extent mbs had
the original aggie you had the aggie
transfer i've got the guy who apparently
has had at some point in his life hair
transplants and that would be tom brady
my offensive player of the week his hair
does curiously continue to get darker
and darker each week by the way as well
never mind and nevertheless that's just
an observation not a criticism it's it's
up to tom to decide whether to what
extent he's going to make his hair as
dark as johnny cash's but he did come in
and get it done
in the second half of a huge game at
atlanta just from the standpoint of
establishing that they're ready to go
for the postseason they fall behind by
17 points it wasn't 28-3 but it was
close enough and in the second half
brady was spectacular 21 of 29 320 yards
two touchdowns
and of all the teams in the nfc
i believe the buccaneers are the best
suited
best constructed and best equipped
to beat the chiefs in the super bowl
especially since that would happen in
tampa the first team to ever play a
super bowl of course in its home stadium
if the buccaneers can navigate the nfc
playoff field it could be buccaneers
chiefs and again i think the buccaneers
would be the biggest threat to beating
the chiefs in the super bowl not that i
would pick the buccaneers to do it but
they'd be the biggest threat all right
defensive player of the week time mds
who do you have
well i have a guy i would actually love
to see match up with tom brady if it
gets there in the nfc playoff field and
that's bobby wagner the seahawks who i
think has maybe reached the point where
he's been so consistently good for so
many years that maybe we don't mention
him enough but he had another very good
game on sunday he had 13 tackles in that
win over the washington football team
you see he was selected to his seventh
pro bowl this week as well and that
seahawks defense is getting a lot better
early in the season there were big
questions about the seahawks defense
they have really turned things around
bobby wagner is a very big part of that
and i like what they have the potential
to do with experienced guys with
postseason experience on that team i
think they're going to be fun to watch
in these playoffs and i think it won't
just be russell wilson carrying them as
it was early in the season i think they
can win some tough hard fought
battles in the postseason and bobby
wagner is a very big part of that
mds i went with one of the biggest pro
bowl snubs and that's the forest buckner
and he was mad that he didn't get the
pro bowl he's not gonna get anything for
this award but i did have him as my
defensive player of the week three sacks
was just outstanding four tackles four
quarterback hits
two tackles for loss and a forced fumble
has really really been good and i think
he's got a good chance mike to make the
all-pro team this year
yeah we've seen that before too guys
that don't make it to the pro bowl that
end up on the old pro team the all pro
team is more difficult i think eric
kendricks did that last year snub in the
pro bowl made it to the all pro team my
defensive player of the week devin white
i'm sticking with the buccaneers he had
three sacks against the falcons they're
going to need better defense not their
defense has been bad but they're going
to need better defense in the postseason
if they want to get to the super bowl
then obviously they need great defense
if they want to slow down the chiefs
enough to outscore them all right we got
to keep moving here rookie of the week
time mds who do you have
james robinson of the jaguars he has to
get some attention scored his 10th
touchdown of the season went over
1400 yards from scrimmage the jaguars
cut leonard fournette a former number
four overall pick before the season and
at the starting job to robinson an
undrafted rookie he's proven himself
more than capable he's having one of the
best undrafted rookie seasons in nfl
history
sometimes mds we forget those players in
the thirsty night games but it's hard to
forget justin herbert in the job he did
had the one yard touchdown run in
overtime to win that game on thursday
night went over 300 yards and amazingly
anthony anthony lynn didn't screw it up
with some game management clock
management situation chargers were able
to win and herbert was outstanding
and uh for me rookie of the week i was
uh got off my page here and i've also
how can i forget sullivan ahmed i talked
to him after the game on sunday he was
awesome he had 122 rushing yards on 23
carries for a dolphins team that needed
a smash mouth running game to complement
to a tonga by low and not expose him
against the patriots in a game the
dolphins had to have it is amazing to me
when you look at the afc between the
dolphins colts texans ravens browns one
of those teams is not going to make it
to the postseason the dolphins needed
that win or they would have been in
danger of being the team that gets
kicked to the curb so sullivan ahmed and
also the great story about his grandma
being in the hospital he told her he'd
get 100 yards he did and he took her a
football from the touchdown that he
scored coach of the week time mds who do
you have
i have matt maggie who i thought maybe
was coaching for his job when the bears
went on that six-game losing streak and
now they've started to turn it around
they've gotten back to seven and seven
they're only a game out of the wild card
it's it's gonna be tough for them to get
to the playoffs but they may still get
there i wasn't so sure that matt maggie
could save his job when they were on
that long losing streak but he's got
trubisky playing better nagi is doing a
much better job i think overseeing the
whole team now and i think he may have
saved his job with a big win over the
vikings
mds i'm going with sean mcdermott for
obvious reason third playoff trip in
four years first division title since
1995. he's done a great job in buffalo
and if it weren't for kevin stefanski i
think we'd be talking about sean
mcdermott as coach of the year
yeah there's a lot of people saying
mcdermott should be coach of the year
but it's always in my view the extent to
which a team exceeds its expectations
coming into the season the expectations
were already high for buffalo they
weren't nearly as high for the browns
and the browns have a chance to win
their division as well what a strange
potential outcome the bills winning the
afc east and the browns winning the afc
north for me i'm going to go to the afc
north basement zach taylor hey
look
this is kind of like the kid that's
brought home straight d's all year and
shows up with straight a's in the final
report card but still you get credit for
the straight a's i'm not happy with how
the bengals performed this year i don't
like the fact that joe burrow got
injured but i like the fact that zach
taylor had his guys focused last night
it was basically their super bowl they
came out and they got it done and beat
the steelers we're gonna take a break
we'll be back with more pft pm right
after this
you